here is election night rules you know it
goes big desk large panel of experts
lots of talking and all over by 6:00
a.m. not this time
because this is an election like no
other and we've invented some new rules
we'll be live at more counts than ever
before using the latest digital
technology to bring more than 250 peak
outs and decorations live into our
results hub here a brand new digital
result system designed to bring you the
most up-to-date results swings share and
projections whatever device you're using
stunning graphics making it all crystal
clear and a brand-new sky election video
printer with all the detail when the
results start coming you won't miss a
thing
we won't be in the studio all night
we'll have presentation teams in all the
right places making sure you get all the
pictures the stories and the latest news
lines as we pursue all the major players
wherever they are and for the first time
ever you'll be able to see exactly what
goes on behind the scenes we've
installed 25 extra cameras around the
newsroom and the sky Studios so you can
see the entire production unfold live we
don't have an off air time we'll be here
until it's done however long it takes on
TV radio phone tablet or online you
won't miss a thing with Sky News